we here at maxtech have used quite a few
projectors before but never anything
like these new portable laser projectors
sent to us from our sponsor nebula the
capsule 3 laser which is battery powered
and the cosmos laser 4K which has
incredible HDR so to give both of these
a proper review with all of our thoughts
and suggestions I went ahead and took
the smaller one home to test out with my
family and let me tell you right now I
was blown away by the quality the
brightness the battery life the
smoothness of the UI and more and then
Max took the cosmos home to his legit
home theater with a huge projector
screen so he's going to be sharing his
thoughts and reviewing this one but
first I've got to talk about the capsule
3 laser because it honestly blew me away
being by far the best projector I've
seen or tested for multiple reasons
first of all this thing is Tiny it's
literally smaller than the coffee I got
this morning check that out you could
probably fit this thing in your pocket
you know what let's do a test right here
on camera yep it fits it fits in my
pocket but the crazy thing is that you
don't need anything to set it up because
it's basically a smart TV built into a
portable projector with Android TV 11
which works great and I'll get into that
in just a minute now the first time I
tested this thing out I set it up
against the inside of a donut box and
started streaming movies from basically
any streaming platform like Netflix HBO
Max Amazon Prime or Apple TV plus but
what really blew my mind about it was
that it was that bright thanks to it
being a laser projector and not LED like
others on the market and all while being
completely battery powered yes it has
2.5 hours of battery life which is
basically enough for most movies out
there and that's due to its laser engine
technology being 1.8 times brighter than
LED at the same wattage now I tested it
out in multiple locations like at my
mother-in-law's house in the basement
using their projector screen in my own
living room against a quick hanging
sheet solution over my fireplace and I
even took it outside and set it up
against my white vinyl fence for a big
screen experience with some blankets and
surprisingly even though our Wi-Fi
connection is terrible outside I was
able to connect it with no issues at all
with no buffering while streaming some
cartoons on YouTube and I love that the
included remote has a little autofocus
and auto Keystone button that you simply
press to refocus if it was bumped or
moved without needing to go up to it and
manually adjust it in a nice little
inclusion is a little mount on the
bottom so you can set it up on a tripod
for a more stable and higher up Solution
on the back you'll find an HDMI 2.1 Port
which is really nice and a USBC port for
either charging or even for connecting
media and an auxiliary port if you want
to Output the audio to a speaker system
but the one thing that shocked me the
most was the built-in 8 watt speaker
that not only got crazy loud but the
quality was also really good with a
Dolby Digital plus certification just
hear it for yourself if we want to go
fast we need to transform
I know we can be high speed
so because that great sound quality it
also doubles as a Bluetooth speaker with
10 plus hours of battery life simply
press this button on the back to go into
Bluetooth speaker mode and connect to it
now the image quality itself was
actually incredible with 1080p
resolution and very impressive contrast
and color reproduction with HDR 10 plus
certification which looks great and you
can even expand out to a full
150 inch projector screen which is
massive and finally the last piece of
the puzzle is the software and UI
because if it doesn't work well it'll
ruin the entire experience but
thankfully the Android TV 11 software
was very nice and responsive with no
issues at all along with a ton of
different apps on the App Store to
choose from and I was pleasantly
surprised by the remote and how reliable
it was and as the last little cherry on
top if you forget the remote the capsule
3 user comes with touch controls on the
top with navigation buttons volume and a
back button as well so after using it
for a while I've realized that this is
basically the best all-around projector
I could ever imagine due to the
combination of the portability the fact
that it's battery powered the speaker
quality the laser image quality and the
UI basically making it a killer TV
replacement for people like me who don't
actually want a TV in their house now
with that said let's move over to Max
for his review of the cosmos laser 4K
before I get into the differences
between the two now I do have multiple
TVs in my house as well as a theater
room which I've dreamed about for over a
decade I love Cinema and I'm so blessed
to be able to have a setup that our
family can enjoy without having to go
out to the theaters now when I set this
up just a year ago I looked into laser
projectors but they were so expensive
that I settled on a regular DLP 4K
projector that was really well rated by
but now nebula released this 4K
projector which is not only laser but it
is also portable with the handle built
into it as far as physical connections
you have an AUX a USB HDMI and the power
connector and you get a 4K Android TV
that pops into a hidden slot in the back
which means that you could theoretically
swap it out in the future now it
supports everything including Netflix
which my projector doesn't for some
reason you get a Smart Remote as well as
physical controls on the top or you can
just use their app which is very
convenient now I was blown away by the
image especially when you consider the
price my 4K projector like I said it's
really well rated but an issue with
projectors is that blacks look great and
the highlights don't pop much even with
HDR this is where the nebula Cosmos 4K
blew me away now you can't see the full
difference recorded by a camera through
YouTube's compression but the contrast
is better with blacks look looking more
black and Shadow details having more
gradation and separation what's even
crazier are the highlights which blew my
mind once I saw those first lightning
bolts blasting across my screen they are
much brighter and actually look like
true HDR from a really really good TV
compared to my DLP projector which still
looks flat even though it is technically
HDR the difference is massive not only
that but the color reproduction is
amazing with the laser projector just
look at the difference in colors with
the HDR image it is not only saturation
or the brightness of the color but the
actual usable color range like in this
flower shot where my DLP projector looks
mostly purple but the laser has a wide
gradient of colors now the biggest
Nemesis two projectors is ambient
lighting which turns a good image to a
super washed out one as you guys could
see the nebula isn't rated any brighter
than my good 4K project injector but
with ambient lighting you could still
see A Brighter Image with the brights
popping more and better colors as well
so why is it such a big difference well
with the standard projector you have one
lamp that shines white light and then
has to make color out of that whereas
here we have three lasers that output
more light and color resulting in a
brighter more contrasty and more Vivid
and color accurate image the way that
the filmmakers intended and get this the
price of the nebula Cosmos 4K laser
projector is practically the same as my
projector which is why it is so special
since other laser projectors are much
much more expensive so you cannot get a
better image for the price than with
this it's also portable and it has a 30
watt speaker system with two mid drivers
that deliver surprising bass as well as
two tweeters for the highs overall the
nebula Cosmos 4K performed way better
than I expected and now I'll be
replacing my DLP projector knowing just
how much better the image looks in every
way and now if you're wondering what's
different between these two nebula
projectors the biggest difference is
obviously the portability and the fact
that the capsule 3 laser is battery
powered offering more flexibility the
cosmos laser 4K is also much heavier
being 10.7 pounds instead of only around
2 pounds on the capsule and it's also
quite a bit more expensive at twenty two
hundred dollars compared to a hundred
dollars retail for the capsule 3 laser
so basically the cosmos is meant for the
high-end use cases where you can still
take it with you on the go while the
capsule 3 laser is more for the common
family or person who wants not only a
high quality projector but a smart one
with Android TV that's incredibly easy
to set up and put away with really good
built-in speakers and one that you can
take anywhere with no wires thanks to it
being battery powered so once again
thank you nebula for sponsoring this
review and if you're interested in
either of these two laser projectors
you'll find lace of them down below in
the description and pin comment thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video